votre saleté les byzantins appels à
l'aide les ottomans autant dire que les
constantinois miséricorde
devons-nous abandonné le dernier bastion
de la chrétienté en terre d'orient
cirque mais remettent de est remonté sur
le trône
il rassemble ses armes et autour d'un
drink insultant déchu ne peut rien face
à la grandeur de notre cité les
troisièmes commis dont on tourne
monseigneur les ottomans sont portés
pour la marche
peuple de constantine abl
principaux points memo
car des heures sombres s'annoncent nous
devons défendre la cité cot cot
rejoignez vos postes mes frères la fin
de l'oppression et au pot de volant mais
sir les ottomans sont à nos portes
ils sont des milliers et prier que dieu
protège notre cité vers la victoire